This is a download from BBC Learning English. To find out more, visit our website.
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBC Learning English. I'm Sam.
And I'm Rob. Now, on Friday the 29th of June 1975, movie posters appeared in cinemas all over
the USA with the now notorious words you'll never go in the water again. So, do you know which movie
was being promoted, Sam? Yes, I think it was George, Steven Spielberg's infamous horror movie,
which terrified a generation with its story of a man eating great white shark with a taste for
revenge and for human flesh. George multiplied people's fascination with and fear of sharks.
But sharks' fearsome reputation is not based on facts. Most attacks on humans are cases of
mistaken identity, where the shark mistakes a swimmer for fish. In recent years, the average
annual number of worldwide deaths from shark bites was as low as four. Today, sharks should be the
apex predators of the ocean, the top predator that hunts and eats other animals but has no natural
predator of its own. Instead, over 100 million sharks are caught and killed each year,
and thanks to this overfishing, many shark species are now endangered. We'll hear more soon,
but first I have a question for you, Rob. Approximately, how many different species of shark
exist today? Is it A, 330, B, 530 or C, 730?
Will I take a guess at B, 530? Okay, I'll reveal the correct answer later in the program.
Now, as Sam mentioned, jaws made many people nervous about swimming in the sea,
largely thanks to scenes in the movie showing the shark biting swimmers in a frenzy of teeth and
blood. George Burgess has spent 40 years studying the cause of shark attacks in his job as director
of the Florida program for shark research. According to him, the movie's depiction of great whites
is totally unrealistic as he told BBC World Service Program, The Inquiry.
Well, a single shark that's involved in a bite on a human, be more likely to bite another human
in the future. In other words, is there something of the jaw's image as we saw, unfortunately,
of which you had a white shark that apparently had a grudge and would try to go after a
human, or nothing could be farther from the truth than that? In the movie, sharks
operate as vengeful creatures who recognize and try to kill individual people.
The shark in jaws had a grudge, a feeling of anger or hatred towards someone because of what
they did in the past. According to marine biologist George Burgess, this is nothing like the real
behavior of sharks in the wild. He says nothing could be further from the truth, an expression
used to emphasise that something is not true at all. The actual truth is that sharks have been
perfectly designed by evolution for their ocean environment. In fact, they have hardly changed
over the last 400 million years, making them even older than the dinosaurs.
Sharks' characteristic design, their thin teeth and skin, allows them to thrive in their natural
environment. Listen to Oliver Krimman, senior curator at London's Natural History Museum,
explaining more to BBC World Service programme, The Inquiry.
If we look at the really successful features of sharks, you've got to consider this
cartolegionous skeleton. That's no bone in the skeleton. That flexible material that the skeleton
is made of enables sharks to be very agile and it enables them to be athletic and it's like weight.
Sharks skeletons are made of cartolegge, not bone. Cartolegge is a strong flexible tissue
which connects joints in the bodies of living creatures. Feel for the boning material in the
fold of your ear. That's cartolegge. Not having bones allows sharks to be both flexible,
able to bend without breaking and agile, able to move their body quickly and easily.
Boneless, bendy and built for speed, sharks really are the perfect evolutionary design.
Yet overfishing and the crawl practice of thinning, cutting off shark fins to make exotic soups
and returning the wounded creature to the sea to die, are threatening shark numbers.
Which is why it's tragic that so many of their species are facing extinction.
And speaking of shark species, what was the answer to your question, Sam?
Hmm, in my quiz question, I asked how many species of shark there are in existence?
Yeah, and I guess it was around 530 different species.
Which was the correct answer, Rob. And the variety of shark species is incredible,
from giants like the great white to the tiny dwarf lantern shark.
Okay, let's recap the vocabulary from this program all about sharks, the ocean's apex predator.
That's the top predator that hunts other animals but has no predators of its own.
If you hold a grudge, you have feelings of anger towards someone because of something they did in the past.
The phrase nothing could be further from the truth is used to emphasize that something is totally
false. Cutledge is the strong flexible tissue connecting bones or joints in the body.
Flexible means able to bend without breaking.
And finally, if you're agile, you can move your body quickly and easily.
Hmm, so once again our six minutes are over.
Bye for now.
Goodbye.